this video is sponsored by rosetta stone
boy hancock isn't one of the most
popular characters in one piece because
she's beautiful or because shippers have
taken over the fandom
but because she represents the core
values and themes of the story like
almost no other character and in this
video i will tell you
exactly what those characteristics are
how oda designed boa hancock to tie
together some of the most high stake
parts of the story
before during and after the time skip
and why i believe that the snake
princess will return to the story
sooner than we all might think on the
most superficial level
boa hancock is a character of extremes
when you first get to meet her in the
story she appears to be extremely
arrogant spoiled and cold-hearted
after falling in love with luffy this
quickly changes from total disdain to
suddenly total devotion caring and
thinking about nothing but luffy
and when looking at it from this
perspective it's quite easy to
understand why some people are confused
why hancock enjoys
such popularity in the fandom after all
she seems to go from
saltily cold to clumsily lovestruck
giving her character
an annoying twist just so the main
character can progress in the story
of course the only logical reason why
people like her character then
must be her looks but while hancock has
undoubtedly one of the best
visual female designs in the story her
charm comes from a much more fundamental
and emotional place
because most of the time whenever oda
does something that appears to be
questionable to fans
he usually does so for a deeper reason
and as so often is the case in one piece
the key to understanding her character
lies in her backstory
as you might remember one of the big
reveals about hancock is the mark that
is burned on her back
as a child she and her two sisters were
abducted by slave traders and sold to
the tendrio beto
since it's still a shonen manga oda only
hints at all the horrors that the three
sisters must have gone through during
the captivity but he leaves
no doubt that these experiences left
them deeply traumatized
coming from a nation of women this first
encounter with the world of men
obviously led to an even deeper hatred
and rejection towards any men than
originally was already the case
but the consequences of this past reach
even deeper
uh
hancock is characterized as extremely
cruel and cold-hearted
she's convinced that her beauty is
enough to let her get away with anything
that she wants
and if that ever shouldn't be enough
which it usually is
she still has her own strength oda
caricatures this literal heartlessness
as her kicking puppies and baby seals
but it's meant to embody the pain
vulnerability and insecurity
deep inside of her for years hancock as
a slave had to be fully subservient to
her masters
being treated as nothing but an object
and so after being freed by fisher tyga
it's
only natural that she fully embraced her
new freedom
never to let go of it again however that
also means that accepting or even
acknowledging
any sort of help from others is
impossible as it would make her indebted
to that person and give up even the
tiniest bit of control this is for
instance why she can't seem to thank
elder nayan
monkey ruffy
yet the mark of the celestial dragons
that is burned into her skin
keeps her from truly being free she and
her sisters are terrified to let anyone
else know about it and it serves as a
constant reminder and trigger to the
horrific
past the true irony of her character is
that while her charm and even her devil
fruit powers seem to be centered around
love
lust and romance she herself is not able
to love or
be loved by others she isn't even able
to form any meaningful bonds with her
own people
even though she clearly cares for them
deeply as their queen
after all she took the step to become a
warlord and join hands with the world
government
the very same government that had caused
her so much
pain just to help her people and help
them live in peace
and so with the reveal of her backstory
we suddenly see that all the arrogance
and coldness we had seen from her up to
that point
is more than just understandable we as
the reader have
now gone from hating her to feeling
empathetic towards her
but how then did that empathy turn into
a genuine fondness for her character
the answer as mostly is the case is her
relationship with
luffy
hancock
which brings me to the sponsor of
today's video
rosetta stone as you might know i speak
three languages
english german and japanese so i'm still
working on that last one i've been
studying for over three years now and
after trying out countless different
ways the
learning technique i personally find the
most effective in the end
is immersion learning where you consume
and learn content that native speakers
also use as
naturally as possible without getting
too stuck in grinding through endless
grammar patterns
and that is exactly what the rosetta
stone app is all about
with more than 250 hours of immersive
content and using words that native
speakers actually use
you get to study more effectively and
with the app you can basically learn
whenever and wherever you want so you
can finally start enjoying your favorite
voice actors without subtitles and get
the fine nuances and many inside jokes
of the japanese language
so if you've been planning to learn
japanese go check out my link in the
description below to get a great
discount on all monthly subscriptions
and better yet there is a lifetime
subscription option as well so you can
pay only once and get access to over 20
different languages
now as i extensively discussed in my
character analysis of luffy
his biggest trait is his conditionless
altruism
he's able to see people's true hearts
and pulls them out of their darkness
for someone who has only known the cruel
egoistic and dominant world of men
luffy's approach to life shattered her
world view completely to illustrate this
point
take this scene which i think is one of
the most important for hancock's
character
[Music]
during the battle in the arena luffy
covers his sister's back
to prevent her slave mark from being
revealed his rationale here was that
this
didn't have anything to do with the
fight and instead of
exploiting her weakness he chose to
respect his enemies emotional weakness
the past is in the past don't bring it
into the present
and this act of respect and kindness
deeply resonated with hancock
to begin with she was already very
shocked that luffy had
no lustful feelings for her whatsoever
and didn't treat her like a queen of
beauty
but just like a normal person and now he
has shown her that one's past
must not necessarily define one's
presence and even though luffy showed
hancock that just like her
he had the qualities of a king he didn't
mind bowing down
and pleading for the life of margarita a
commoner that he became friends with
luffy is a very forgiving person as he
always forgives the mistakes of his crew
without blinking an eye
sanji literally kicked him in the face
until he fell unconscious
yet he forgave him he views his
crewmates as his friends
and not as his underlings boy hancock on
the other hand
based on her experience is not very
forgiving
she expects obedience and she expects
everyone to live up to her expectations
we see this even with her own sisters
[Music]
and yet as her true self is that of a
very kind and caring person
luffy's personality resonated deeply
with her so
deeply that she has fallen head over
heels for him
not because luffy is strong but because
of what he stands for and who he is
which is very genuine love and so
ironically enough
the only person her love powers won't
work on
is the one person she's genuinely in
love with luffy
enabled her to show more of her true and
vulnerable self
to form relationships with her people
and to let go of her past and embrace
the future
and while loving boy hancock can turn
you into stone
luffy has taken her own stony heart and
brought it back to life
allowing her to trust and love again
this change of heart
pun absolutely intended was so intense
for her that she literally fell
ill being overwhelmed with emotions that
she had suppressed for so long
and so what makes it almost impossible
for us not to fall in love with a
character in return
is the fact that we went from one
extreme to the other with her
at the beginning hanko gave us one
reason after the next to dislike her
after falling in love with luffy however
she's basically giving us reason after
reason
after reason to like her she's the one
that helps him get into impul down
to free his brother she talked to a's
about him covering for him
and she gave luffy the keys to his
handcuffs and finally
she was the one to protect him and take
him in after ace's death
and the events of the time skip all of
this was neither required nor
expected of her and it shows us just how
genuinely she cares for luffy
without any ulterior motives and while
some people seem to dislike this
innocent
and girly side of her those of us with a
heart understand that this is simply the
honest side of a traumatized girl
that has started to heal and has fallen
in love for the very first time
and that care that she has for luffy and
the willingness to sacrifice
everything for him is what makes her so
popular
because her love for luffy is an
extension of
ours for him as well hancock unites all
of the core themes and values of one
piece
freedom love the cruelness of the world
and most importantly why luffy is the
one who has to change everything
and with the abolishment of the warlord
system her enormous power and her
relationship with luffy i think it's
just
extremely probable that she'll make a
reappearance in the story very soon oda
even hinted at her
sabo and vivi playing major roles in the
story once again at some point
so i think we can all be very excited
for that and i recommend that you check
out my two videos on luffy's character
here thanks for watching peace